i've been playing a [ __ ] ton of chess
do you like it
yeah i love it but i suck ass
did you know that all these chess grand
masters are like twitch superstars yeah
[ __ ] wild it's such a rabbit hole so
funny i watched one chess video and now
my whole recommendation
is chess people and these twitch chess
stars like you just unlocked they're
like oh you're into chess well here's a
whole world yeah it's pretty wild i had
no idea and then i fell into that
uh i was watching charlie and xqc play
uh it can become very vulnerable right
away so i'm not sure that
[Music]
no please don't and it's too soon
[Music]
yeah no chess was hot on twitch you play
chess i
learned and i just know like the
standard opening not very good but i
like it it's so fun it's a good game
yeah yo when they came out of chess they
knew they were doing man it's classic i
actually on that subject of weird ass
old games i got a weird recommended
video
for some game i i can't remember the
name it's french but it's like
no i think it's um
my dick
suck my dick i think that's the name of
the game
it's like a table tabletop it's like a
it's almost a small maze it's got pins
set up that count as points and
so the top is in a locked position it's
it's a weird variation of pinball almost
and so you lock the top in on one side
of the table and then you rip it
and then it just goes through whatever
this little mazes and knocks down pins
and you collect games it's like a it's
like a rich people game that sounds
awesome yeah it made me want to buy a
table wait it's a real life game yeah
yeah there's this tick tock account that
shows it's like a ramp that just has a
like little bumper walls basically that
like push into a v sort of i think and
then there's like pokey audi things in
the middle i think and you like they
like release all these pool balls and
you you basically like the idea of the
tick tock account is you bet on which
one's going to hit the bottom and like
oh yeah they post a new video yeah i
loved how i mean i tweeted about this
but i loved how all those dudes that you
know like billiard ball races on the
treadmills and all those like uh gimmick
streams on tick tock yeah new year's day
then [ __ ] were on you know just
like day one like nah we're back at it
dude's trying to chuck in the cd into a
into a wii super far away yeah you know
what i mean
trick shot tick tocks
this is skittles all right this is this
is the oh let's [ __ ] go i've seen
this already this is the bozo version of
the game this looks like the penis wall
from perverse family it does
the glory has messed you up you just
want to jerk off all those pins
that's right
[Music]
what is that thing is that a top yeah
like their that top
[Music]
sucks now show him
hollandaise and lock the top in that's a
real top right there that's a beyblade
that's the original beyblade yep that's
a man's top
yeah
oh let's see you launch this thing gary
oh
what this is sick get busy
so do you bet on how many pins oh it
just eventually gets them all no you
don't always get them all so there there
are like way more intricate tables
this one's like really simple you can
better yeah
so this is what the rich people played
you couldn't be a you know
regular
playing
[Laughter]
this is way better than
an nft for a [ __ ] restaurant oh look
at this one oh my god beautiful
yeah golden arches you know it was sick
characters maybe classy you know mm-hmm
yeah
yeah uh we need to go the other way with
it everyone's trying to go into vr and
stuff we need to buy up all the
antiques
uh bourgeoisie rich people games from
[ __ ] 1800
yeah bringing all that [ __ ] to the idea
yeah
we you know [ __ ]
what does everyone say like all the [ __ ]
boys on instagram like
real life does not eat or like internet
does not equal real life yeah like my
life is way sicker than i could ever
portray like we're just posted up beside
for what are they called what was the
game called
oh no it's called uh suck my dick sock i
think my balls to pee all in days we're
just posted up beside four toupee
hollandaise tables
yeah like [ __ ]
[ __ ] the metaverse this is real life
[ __ ]
the metaverse we do real verse dude real
real verse like this we do real verses
it'll be us two and jeff head down
skittle hollandaise [ __ ]
you know another hollandaise
another weird one i found i don't know
how i mean don't you love how an
algorithm could just dictate your life
that's something i always wonder are
people sad or just did the algorithm do
that to them you know what's the
sensitivity does it take one murder
mystery documentary and then netflix is
like oh [ __ ]
we're gonna make this dude depressed
dude
we just you just ruined your own [ __ ] oh
he likes murder boys
let's take him down let's make him sad
you know i don't know that's a good
question it's kind of a chicken and egg
kind of issue isn't it yeah
yeah which came first the user or the
algorithm yeah exactly the algorithm
needs something to feed off of it needs
one little morsel and then it can run
with it i found a
different skittles it's called london
skittles it's basically like bowling
without the lane they played this [ __ ]
in pubs
and they set up pins
uh kind of like in a diamond but it's
actually just a square
so
picture squared and rotate it so like
the point is facing the player
and you stand like i don't know like 10
or 15 feet away and you're holding
like a
old cheese wheel and you just gotta
huck it and throw it and try to knock
all the pins down you get as many tries
and you know the goal is to get them all
in one and one wipe like a strike i want
europeans man they're classier you know
way way classier
what do we have carnival games
yeah that's kind of cool though we have
that game at a bar where you
it's a little ring hanging on a string
and you got to get on the hook that game
actually [ __ ] rules though those are
call of duty and we we you know we beat
the [ __ ] out of the british in that all
the time we gotta say yes every time so
you know
that's a good point
who's got the better game honestly
yeah
that's why they made all those goofy
little games because we were out there
fighting the real war you know us dual
citizen americans we were out there
fighting the real [ __ ] dude i wanted to
make a video where i i wanted to remake
these games but instead of like the
designated like ball or cheese wheel or
whatever i just wanted to do it with a
[ __ ] with a baby ah welcome everyone
for tuning in to baby lunch
today we have a wonderful lineup of
players this is your host
bogdanov
alright [ __ ] man
in honor of both bogdanov brothers we
have
baby lunch
all day 24 hours to enter these
tournaments you have to put down at
least
three ethereum
it's a bunch of americans just
[ __ ]
throwing the baby
love 14.